the great resignation um i think is um
it's a market correction
you know we know what happens to public
markets when they become unbalanced
right um
laws of nature intervene and there is a
correction that's what happens and i
think what we're experiencing is a
massive correction in the labor market
where for too many years uh let's be
honest companies have taken advantage of
their people especially uh low-level
employers because they could and they
actually had attitudes like if you don't
like it here get a job somewhere else
you know um
and
um and we didn't treat people as human
beings we treated them as line items
disposable line items and the front
lines suffered the most you know
and um and that balance got more and
more and more
tipped and now what we're experiencing
is a great correction where now uh uh
labor has much more influence and says
and thanks to covid says i don't want to
be treated this way and i'd rather have
no job than this job now remember prior
to covid um fear of the unknown was
enough to keep somebody in an okay job
doesn't mean it was toxic it was just
fine right
um but like who wants to be in a fine
relationship you know i mean a fine job
either like how was work that's fine you
know how's your marriage and that's fine
right
but the fear of the unknown was too
scary why don't you quit i would but i
mean i don't know right and then covet
happened and some people were furloughed
some people lost their jobs some people
didn't lose their jobs but they were
filled with fear
and
we made it through
and so all of a sudden the unknown
a lot less scary
because i made it and so when you give
me fine and you offer me unknown
i'll take unknown
and i'm really surprised by how many
people are leaving look you're going to
have a small percentage of people who
are leaving because of government checks
that's a very small percentage and that
goes away you have a small percentage of
people who like you know what
i want to be a singer and i want to
follow my dreams we love that right and
that should continue but there's a large
percentage of people saying i just don't
want this
and i don't even know what i want but
it's definitely not this and they're
choosing the unknown and so i think it's
a huge shot across the bow to most
companies that you've not focused on
culture and leadership for far too long
and you better fix that because this is
this is kind of an environment of your
making and
um
and it's and it affects all ranks as you
know it's not just junior ranks but i
think it's a great opportunity and again
i think it's an opportunity for your
practice that to help companies who are
concerned about this to double down on
culture and give people a place that
they want to go to work that they feel
seen that they feel heard
that they feel like they have a voice
they feel like their work contributes to
something bigger than themselves that
their energy is not just about helping
somebody else
uh uh make money but rather they get to
share in in the joy and the spoils um i
think it's a huge huge opportunity for
your practice to teach companies how to
do this i think they've you know you're
used to solving business problems while
ignoring culture problems and look at
look at a lot of the unicorns you know
whether it's groupons or or ubers or you
know or game stops i mean pic pic pick
you're not games up i mean uh robin hood
robin hood yeah pick your poi and pick
your pick your uh your unicorn
almost every single one of them
the reason things got shaky had nothing
to do with the business model had it
everything to do with the leadership and
the culture and the fact that they were
completely ill prepared for anything
going other than perfectly according to
plan which as it turns out you know no
plan ever goes according to plan
i think it's a huge opportunity for you
to actually
change the face of of
of how business works
and react to what companies are we know
struggling with